is your smartphone linked to this
there's a good chance this is where your
favorite tech gadget begins the cobalt
mines of the Congo
cobalt is a key component in
rechargeable lithium batteries so it's
needed to manufacture things like
smartphones laptops and electric cars at
human rights groups say often those -
are children and the working conditions
can be deadly
often the miners have to dig by hand the
tunnel straight down and 50 meters
sometimes into the shale we heard
stories of up to 65 people in one
incident including adults and children
were buried alive and they didn't even
find their bodies yet there are no
official statistics on fatalities but
miners have told human rights groups
that they risk injury or death whenever
they work in unregulated mines now
Congolese families want to hold Apple
Google Dell Tesla and Microsoft
accountable us-based Human Rights
nonprofit is suing the tech giants on
behalf of 14 families it's the first
time the tech industry has faced legal
action over the mining of COBOL my 14
clients are either children who have
been maimed or the parents of children
who have been killed in mining accidents
which are very routine there's a boy
with an amputated leg there's several
boys with smashed legs they'll never
work again
in the Democratic Republic of Congo and
they need medical attention
[Music]
according to court documents families
claimed the children were paid as little
as two dollars a day and tech companies
are alleged to have been aware of the
child labor here's how some companies
have responded
[Music]
[Music]
part of the problem according to experts
is that it's nearly impossible for tech
giants to be sure the cobalt they're
buying doesn't come from child labor in
the end of the day even if children are
not working in mines controlled by big
companies their productions end up in
the supply chain in the global supply
chain of minerals going out from from
DSC currently what I can say is that
it's very difficult to have 100% green
cobalt come from DRC where we have zero
or child labour I went there for about
two weeks and I managed to interview
children see children that they're
everywhere so it is just unbelievable
for them to say that they're not aware
or that they have fixed this problem
estimates vary a thousands of child
miners are believed to be working congos
cobalt mines we are finishing a study in
Colosimo Katanga and our estimate is
about 30,000 children of age under 15
years who are now working in the mind
one study places some of the blame on
Kongos rampant corruption there's no
government regulation the government is
extremely corrupt often the government
has been paid off to look the other way
but no one had ever heard of something
called a mine inspector so we need
people on site inspecting the mines we
need safety regulations and then there
has to be a severe consequence for
violating these rules actionable change
on this issue will take time
the lawsuit filed by international
rights advocates still has no set trial
date by global demand for cobalt
continues to rise
you